german reunification not only brought
together two very different cultures but
also two completely different economic
systems the german development bank kfw
was one of the key players involved in
this mammoth task from the very
beginning and the head of the KfW bank
is with us today voguish carta thanks a
lot for joining us once again I'd like
to begin by asking you what the
objective was of the KfW bank after
reunification the objective s for a
promotional bank like ours is to help
where help is needed mostly and we
determined three areas where help was
necessary one was to rebuild and
restructure again a commercial sector
that was particularly a sector of small
and medium-sized enterprises which was
completely non existing and we put about
100 billion into this activity so
founding new companies supporting
growing companies the second activity
was in the housing stocks are housing
stock was in a very bad shape so we put
about 70 billion of euros in the housing
stock every second new building in
patrolling and joy in East Germany was
supported by our financing and the third
was the infrastructure and altogether
from your figures you mentioned in your
trailer be about put about ten percent
of the over funding into eastern Germany
with so many different areas to look
after what would you say was the most
challenging the most challenging is
probably to change the culture and I'm
amazed to see how quickly the sculpture
was changing so the willingness to open
up new companies to open up to a new
democratic society to open up to
competition I'm really amazed to see how
quickly that went well of course when we
look back hindsight is always
twenty-twenty as they say are there
things that you would have done
differently I think in principle we did
the right things the privatization of
the industry was done very quickly
probably the underestimated the time and
speed it would take in order to change
cycler like Zetas society I think we
have reached very good results but we
had hoped probably when you really claim
chance a call at the time we hope
probably for more in a shorter period
and beyond the right track it takes
probably a bit longer but also today if
you compare eastern Germany alone with
other countries in Europe they are in a
very good track and yet despite all of
the efforts despite all of the
investment there are still substantial
differences between east and west for
example in terms of employment levels or
income levels why does that still linger
why do those changes still linger it's
it's a question of timing and the income
levels for example have improved
significantly they're still lower in
eastern Germany's and they are in the
West but if you look at the gaps we saw
in 1991 and we see today that has
significantly be reduced if you look at
unemployment rates at the beginning of
this period and now they have been
reduced significantly but yes you're
right there is still a room for
improvement there are a number of
activities which you have to do we have
to do increase the producing sector in
eastern Germany they have to to do more
on the on the educational front so there
are a number of activities which still
need to be improved yes and we do hope
that they will be improved okay sure to
thank you so much for talking to us here
I made in Germany was the pleasure